bueno nosotros no nos encargamos
concretamente de búsqueda de rescate
sino más bien de ayuda de ayuda
humanitaria el procedimiento es
complicado requiere maquinaria requiere
técnicos especialistas requiere perros
de búsqueda y lógicamente tiene que ser
muy rápido las primeras 72 horas de las
cuales ya la mitad han pasado son claves
para encontrar personas con vida
y bueno la gente está desesperada El
problema es que la magnitud del
terremoto ha sido enorme hay 10
provincias afectadas a pesar de que el
gobierno movilizado una enorme cantidad
de rescatistas y han venido otros de
otros países no se llega a todas las
localidades a todos los zonas que han
sido afectadas por el terremoto de ahí
las quejas que se oían ahora mismo la
entrada de las noticias hablaba usted de
estas 72 horas posteriores al hecho que
son clave no se estima que este es el
tiempo promedio que tardan las
autoridades en tomar el control de este
tipo de situaciones no teniendo en
cuenta las dimensiones de la tragedia
podría llegar a controlarse en este
periodo
no no creo porque como digo hay
muchísima gente afectada es una zona muy
poblada hay varios ciudades como adana
que se mencionan tienen dos millones de
habitantes son ciudades enormes y están
devastadas por el terremoto es imposible
que haya maquinaria seguramente para
atender a todos Hasta mañana ya se
habían rescatado como ocho mil personas
debajo de los escombros que es una
cantidad muy grande los esfuerzos
seguirán Incluso se encontrarán gente
afortunadamente esperemos Más allá de
las 72 horas pero hay que tener en
cuenta que también el clima es duro está
lloviendo hace frío y eso dificulta no
solo la labores de rescate sino también
la capacidad de sufrimiento y de
supervivencia de las personas que están
bajo los
comentaba bueno que usted se enfoca más
en lo que son las tareas de ayuda
humanitaria no pero quisiera consultarla
aprovechando no que está en France 24
qué pasa con las personas que fueron
rescatadas En qué estado las encontraron
a dónde fueron derivadas
Bueno hay una buena red de hospitales y
de centros de salud a los cuales están
llevando con ambulancias y demás ese no
es problema el realmente el problema más
grave es las personas que todavía están
debajo y que no pueden pueden salir no y
el otro problema es que hay hay cientos
de miles de personas literalmente que no
pueden volver a sus casas por el riesgo
de temblores y estamos tratando de
trabajar para darles tiendas de campaña
mantas calentadores etcétera para que
puedan permanecer fuera de sus casas
mientras se verifica que pueden volver
necesita necesita hacer una inspección
técnica para poder para poder regresar a
sus casas no aparte de que la gente
tiene ahora mismo pánico claro
traumatizada después de los terremotos y
de los numerosos temblores que ha habido
después usted está en Turquía maneja
información sobre cómo avanzan las
tareas en Siria
en Siria Efectivamente es más complicado
Siria tiene ahora una triple crisis
porque llevaba meses afectados por una
epidemia de cólera además hay un
conflicto como todo el mundo sabe la
guerra civil no ha acabado y hay zonas
bajo control de fracciones armadas que
es más difícil el acceso para los para
los actores humanitarios en ese sentido
y además hay una crisis económica muy
complicada por lo tanto las tareas de
rescate y de respuesta
el centro de los centros de salud los
hospitales etcétera están mucho más
colapsados no tienen las capacidades que
hay en Turquía por lo tanto me Temo que
la suerte de las víctimas en Turquía
pueda ser peor que que en este